dieses objekt könnte noch krasser sein
als die stories in star wars ein
internationales forschungsteam hat es
jetzt in einer entfernung von 550
lichtjahren aufgespürt es geht um einen
möglichen exo mond also ein mond
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems er
besteht wahrscheinlich aus gestein und
brodelnder lava und gleicht einer
unvorstellbaren vulkane klicks um
science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannendes seines videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken und dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es wäre eine gefährliche
vulkanische welt mit einer geschmolzen
oberfläche aus lava ein ort wo ladies
den tod finden wie anakin skywalker weiß
so beschreibt ab ovo zu einer der
beteiligten forscher von der universität
bern den nun aufgespürten exelon diese
entdeckung wird schon jetzt als eine
echte premiere gefeiert wenn es könnte
sich um den ersten vulkanisch aktiven
mond handeln der einen exo planeten
umkreist wenn er tatsächlich existieren
sollte handelt es sich wohl wirklich um
eine exotische vulkan hölle und diese
umkreis nach angaben des forschungsteams
den gasriesen rost 49 b ein exoplanet
der 550 lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist
dass dieser heiße riesenplaneten
möglicherweise von einem extrem mond
umkreist wird schließt das berner
forschungsteam aus spektrum grafischen
untersuchungen gasförmiges kalium und
natrium befindet sich demnach in sehr
hoher dichte und an überraschenden
stellen im umfeld des exoplaneten so
schreiben es die experten und
expertinnen in ihrer studie laut dem
forscher ab rosa ist das neutrale nazi
um gas so weit vom planeten entfernt
dass es höchstwahrscheinlich nicht bloß
von einem planetaren wind ausgestoßen
wird und so ziehen die forschenden den
vergleich mit dem jupitermond namens er
gilt als der vulkanisch aktiv siemens
körper in unmittelbarer nachbarschaft
der erde
hier wird unvorstellbar viel lava
produziert insgesamt erzeugen die
vulkane auf dem jupitermond hundertmal
mehr lava als alle vulkane zusammen auf
der erde
dabei wird nicht nur natrium sondern
auch kalium gas freigesetzt das dann vom
forschungsteams auf der erde aufgespürt
werden kann
doch der nun möglicherweise neu
entdeckte vulkanische ex und könnte
sogar noch heißer und aktiver sein
als der jupitermond io darauf deutet
zumindest seine gasmenge diese konnte
zudem in außergewöhnlich großer höhe
nachgewiesen werden das gras ist also
weit vom planeten entfernt die aktuelle
studie zeigt zudem auf dass solch ein
kleiner gesteins mond durchaus mehr
kalium und natrium ins als steuern kann
als ein großer gasplanet und zwar einzig
und allein bedingt durch sehr aktiven
vulkanismus dazu der astrophysiker abo
barrosa natrium und kalium
spektrallinien sie sind für uns
astronomen besondere schätze weil sie
äußerst hell sind die alten
straßenlaternen die unsere straße mit
gelben dunst beleuchten funktionieren
mit den gleichen gas das wir jetzt im
spektrum von einem dutzend exoplaneten
entdecken doch warum ist dieser
extrasolare mond in solch hohem ausmaß
vulkanisch aktiv nach angaben des
forschungsteams ist wohl der exoplaneten
gasriese boston und 40 b dafür
verantwortlich was born für wird sich
bereits seinen eigenen trabanten demnach
durch seine uhr und ständig wechselnde
gravitation extrem stark auf in der
studie ist von enormen gezeitenkräfte
die sprache die dafür sorgen dass die
vulkanische aktivität erhalten bleibt
und auch die bahn des mondes weiterhin
stabil bleibt auch das ist vergleichbar
mit jupiter und seinem und eu
denn letzterer wird ebenfalls durch die
extreme schwerkraft von jupiter
regelrecht durchgeknetet einen ersten
extrem kandidaten wollen forschungsteams
übrigens schon vor einiger zeit
aufgespürt haben
es handelt sich um ein mond der den 8
tausend lichtjahre entfernten
exoplaneten keppler 16 25 b und preis
doch auch die existenz dieses neptun
großen trabanten ist noch nicht mit
aller sicherheit geklärt so ist es auch
der fall bei dem vulkanisch aktiven
extremen der möglicherweise um boston 49
b kreis denn auch nicht thermische
prozesse oder aber einen ring aus
ironisierte gas könnte eine rolle
spielen und die forschenden auf eine
falsche spur geführt haben deshalb ist
das forschungsteam jetzt auf intensiver
suche nach weiteren hinweisen mit
anderen teleskopen beispielsweise
könnten noch mehr signaturen
vulkanischer gase aufgespürt werden
erster exo vulkan und entdeckt auch
astro comics tv hat sich mit dem mond
beschäftigt also hier anklicken
anschauen und dem mega mega mega
megacoolen kanal asto comics tv
abonnieren bis dann bleib dran